we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p i don't know
if this voicemail is for real or not but
let's take a listen to it it's about
Bernie's three houses I David it's
calling from site it's calling from
Washington State I had a question about
Bernie Sanders my dad who listened to
conservative radio all the time
he claims that Bernie raised a lot of
money outside of selling his book and
he's got like three houses or something
so I don't know that I believe you know
three houses or something I don't know
that I believe this is a sincere
voicemail but let's let's see if we can
disaggregate this Bernie did not raise
money by selling a book
Bernie wrote a book and that's a
commercial endeavor and he made money
from selling it several many hundreds of
thousands of dollars as would be
expected from a politician of his
stature and notoriety in society Bernie
raised money for his campaign from
individuals and Bernie does have three
houses and what matters is that Bernie
wants health care for everybody
Bernie wants higher taxes on the very
rich to pay for things that would
benefit all of society so on and so
forth Bernie's net worth of I believe it
was 1.1 million dollars is not at all
outrageous for a guy who's nearly 80
years old and has made six figures for
quite some time now as an elected
official at the top level in the United
States and my instinct is that this is
concern fake concern trolling but if
it's a serious question no you don't
have to be worried about that go by the
policies and then you will very quickly
see when you compare Bernie Sanders to
Donald Trump or to Joe Biden whose
policies would be best for the greatest
number of people we've got a great bonus
show for you today we will talk about
Donald Trump ramping up outreach to
black voters after the State of the
Union push we will talk about some
interesting new studies about the
interplay between an individual's brain
chemistry and weather
or not antidepressants will work and
then lastly it turns out that millenials
are better at saving money in the
philosophical sense but still have less
money we'll talk about why that is all
of those stories and more on today's
bonus show